[Musique]
et donc une inuit elle est née à ical
witt et ali vit depuis très très
longtemps même si elle a fait ses études
dans le sud
alors on va également parlé avec nos
deux chroniqueuses isabelle picard
bonjour alors isabelle avec vous on va
parler de divers faits de fait qu'on
connaît un peu moins finalement sur le
nunavut
oui on va c'est de faire connaître le
nunavut davantage aux gens parce qu'il
ya pas beaucoup de québécois ni des
canadiens qui vont ses rangs
malheureusement dit le thé dans les
manifs et on est absolument
et puis ellis queen bonjour oui images
ont alors ellis vous connaissez vous
très bien les enjeux du nunavut parce
que le l'article nord vous le couvrait
déjà depuis plusieurs années mais depuis
décembre voilà est avec vous donc on va
s'intéresser à la langue en fait aux
langues parlées au nunavut
oui alors la langue c'était vraiment un
aspect primordial de le projet nous ne
voulons pas voir ce qu'ils réussissent
ce qu'il réussit pas et puis qu'est-ce
qu'on en est actionnaire d'accor alors
puisque marine n'est pas encore avec
nous on va la rejoindre dans un studio
de siby 6 à ical oui on va parler des
fêtes ya allons-y avec les faits même
s'il ya plein de choses intéressantes à
découvrir sur 7 ha oui j'en suis
terriblement et en faisant mes
recherches jean-noël sortir 20 j'ai
décidé d'en sortir une dizaine d'armes
heures
d'abord le mot nous n'avons qu'est ce
qu'il veut dire en une petite otc la
langue des inuits là bas et ça signifie
notre terre donc des jeux le jeu vous
inscrire oui ça s'inscrit tout à fait
dans les négociations qui ont lieu
et d'ailleurs c'est négociations là
n'ont pas été simples sa peau était
simple de créer le nunavut
les négociations concernant les
revendications territoriales ont
commencé en 1976
ah oui ça fait vraiment longtemps c'est
un processus qui aura duré 33 au bout de
l'est donc en 1963 en fait l'autre euh
oui 25.6 exactement mais c'est long
quand même 23 ans pour aboutir à ces
langues différentes étapes
en fait le gouvernement fédéral avec
l'organisme représentatif de tous les
inuits du canada qui s'appelle le tapis
reset inuit
oui donc se sont rencontrés en 1976 pour
le début finalement des discussions en
avril 82 il ya une majorité des
résidents des territoires du nord-ouest
parce qu'il faut savoir que le nunavut
faisait partie des territoires du
nord-ouest et ce avant il y avait juste
deux territoires le louison les
territoires du nord-ouest les
territoires du nord-ouest était immense
finalement oui absolument absolument
c'était le plus grand territoire et donc
les legends la population des terres
dans le nord-ouest ont voté lors d'un
référendum pour en faveur de la scission
finalement de leur territoire en 92 et
finalement il ya un accord sur les
revendications territoriales qui a été
conclu en juin 93 le parlement du canada
va adopter de lois très importante pour
le nunavut en fait c'est la loi
concernant l'accord sur les
revendications territoriales du nunavut
et la loi sur le nunavut et la
transition va déboucher sur la création
du nunavut le 1er avril 99 donc venus en
bus n'a donc c'est un processus qui a
été vraiment lancé jamais simple 1-2
venons de créer de nouveaux territoires
non maintenant la population mondiale du
nunavut et pas très élevée on parle de
33330 personnes parmi lesquelles on va
trouver 84% d'inuits et 5% d'un look
tonnes finalement près du trois quarts
des inuits ont d'ailleurs moins de 40
ans et environ 40 % vont avoir moins de
15 alors c'est une population qui
résolument très donc 40% de dd jeune
inuit n'ont jamais connu le territoire
en fait notre homme pense que le nunavut
oui tout à fait tout à fait il y avait
25 communautés inuites donc au nunavut
et avec ses 6700 habitants ical ou et
c'est la capitale à moins populeuses du
canada mais c'est quand même ironique
quand on sait que
le territoire du nunavut à ces deux
millions de kilomètres carrés
donc c'est quand même énorme et pour 25
communautés appsfire absolue la
disperser et maintenant comment ils se
déplacent d'un point a au point b où
nous n'avons certainement pas sur 4 ou
parce que le territoire compte à peine
32 km de routes
oui pavé donc n'ayant pas à pleuvoir
énorme qu'elle souhaitait bien sûr
absolument et donc pour passer d'une
communauté à l'autre on va prendre
l'avion la plupart du temps et bien sûr
l'hiver c'est la motoneige qui va servir
de transport à peu près tout le monde
dans les communautés elles surpassent
bien sûr en nombre le nombre de voitures
ça c'est certain
plus de motoneige que nous vêtir et un
autre exemple est évidemment l'été on va
on veut on peut on peut se déplacer à
pied mais les distances au très très
courtes par exemple kalou et il faut 23
minutes de marche pour se rendre de
l'aéroport du kaloum au centre j'ai un
peu traîné une fête d'ailleurs et elie
je vous êtes allé plusieurs fois il n'ya
lutins et vous le faites habituellement
à pied ou en moto n'est moi je suis
toujours là au milieu d'hiver alors
c'est le taxer de taxi man l'accord oui
d'ailleurs pour les taxis je lisais qui
avait un tarif unique pour sa robe elle
peut pas voir ça va se passer quelque
chose de grave nous n'avons même pas
parce qu'à 32 km on va quand même pas
très loin finalement alors c'est pas
très payant pour le taxi et en même
temps on veut pas que ça nous coûte trop
cher mais voilà alors voilà alors c'est
je pense le stade delort c'était
vraiment pas très très cher il ya aussi
au nunavut une fête qu'on célèbre conte
le célèbre nulle part d'autre même au
canada ou ailleurs dans le monde
c'est le premier jour de la saison du
transport maritime en fait il y a de
quoi célébrer parce que c'est le moment
où les gens peuvent faire venir leur
commande d'épicerie par bateau
évidemment oui on peut tout mais entre
autres l'épicerie parce que quand on
sait que une pinte de lait peut coûter
jusqu'à 12 13 14 dollars
ça vaut peut-être la peine de faire
venir des entrées des denrées non
périssables pour l'année oui parce que
le msd fait comment pour le lait du lait
en poudre d'huile ont fait beaucoup de
jeunes plus purement tourneur plus on a
dit oui c'est vrai aussi au nunavik oui
oui partout alors c'est une grosse
commande de produits qu'on fait venir
par bateau et loeb s est une occasion de
finale chalus nunavut une fois en 2000
en fait et c'est ça on m'avait raconté
le bateau partait d'ici de montréal pas
loin devant les fils du port de
valleyfield et ensuite bon il avait un
grand père les affaires pour se rendre
jusque là haut
et il ne s'arrête pas qu'à iqra louis
tilt pros ils se promènent ensuite dans
les petites communautés et les gauchos
jc comme les motoneiges ou les laveuses
où les choses comme ça c'est comme
vraiment c'est là qu'elles soient toutes
les lignes
donc c'est une occasion de célébration
il ya aussi au nunavik les panneaux
signalisation sont généralement en
anglais ou en inuktitut
mais il faut savoir que le français et
l'inouï nac tonnes sont aussi les
langues officielles il y aurait quatre
langues officielles au nunavut avec les
leaders et ont remplacé les maris on va
en parler avec marie marie bellot qui
est là avec nous bonjour marie vélo vous
nous entendez martin bonjour oui oui ça
riait bien sûr il ya un petit décalage
c'est normal vous êtes vraiment loin à
quelques milliers de kilomètres donc on
va prendre notre temps pour vous
entendre
petite question comment ça va en ce
moment et quel temps il fait et kalou et
tant qu'à y être
allons-y avec la météo ok aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup de maintenant on a quand même
beaucoup de nay justement on avait une
sortie prévue avec mon travail mais ça a
dû être annulée parce que les conditions
sont pas sont pas idéales mais ça prend
de la neige on n'a pas eu beaucoup
d'estivants
on va l'accepter et il fait encore froid
tout est relatif bien patronnant
beaucoup
c'est ça c'est le printemps donc oui
encore de la neige mais il fait moins
froid on peut après on peut profiter
l'extérieur on s'est parlé hier avec
marie n'diaye il fait parfois il fait
moins 35 maintenant était relatif alors
[Rires]
marie on revient non on va terminer avec
isabelle elle nous parlait des faits
moins connus de du nunavut à leur écoute
et là bien si vous avez des commentaires
à faire à laizy donc isabelle on était
rendus aux jeunes de rentrer oui en fait
je parlais de l'année langue mais j'ai
envie de vous parler du soleil on vient
parler de la température évidemment
l'hiver au nunavut les journées sont
ultra courtes en décembre par exemple le
soleil peut se coucher un peu se lever à
les morts 25 et il va se coucher aussi
tôt 4h30 13h40
donc on parle de quatre heures
d'ensoleillement on n'était pas celle
inverse aux alentours du solstice d'été
le 20 et 21 juin
ic alouettes par exemple va traverser un
époux un éblouissant 21h de clarté oui
alors se reprend pour la pour la période
oui maintenant deux fait quand même
intéressant toutes les communautés vont
contrôler leur contrôle à l'alcool en
fait nous n'avons aucune communauté en
ce moment à vendre de l'alcool sauf à
kalou et la capitale mais on peut en
trouver dans les restaurants et dans les
bornes
idéalement il ya six communautés qui
interdisent complètement l'alcool
également et un autre fait que je savais
pas c'est la grc qui est responsable des
services policiers partout où nous
n'avons ni eau et les services ne font
que ces potins
ramid et on va pouvoir en parler avec
marie alors marie vous êtes dans les
studios de s'initier call me tient
beaucoup de monde autour de vous et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de bruit ça va
vous nous entendez bien quand même
oui ça va aller bon excellent alors
marie on va parler du territoire dans
lequel vous vivez donc depuis votre
naissance je pense quand même que vous
êtes descendus dans le sud pendant
quelques années pour faire vos études
mais parlez nous du territoire comment
se porte le nunavut
vingt ans après sa création
c'est vraiment une bonne question c'est
une question très très général très
vaste il faudrait peut-être aller dans
les thèmes un petit peu plus précis le
pouvoir c'est quoi exactement que vous
voulez savoir
mais pour vous personnellement comment
c'est sûr qu'on peut parler des lieux du
positif et du négatif on peut vraiment
ça dépend aussi a qui disent pas mais
c'est sûr que les conditions de vie par
exemple sont vraiment pas l'eau on
aimerait qu'il soit c'est encore
difficile
oui ok alors allons-y en parlant du
gouvernement parce que ça ça va vraiment
nous situer on peut expliquer le
gouvernement qui est en place quel genre
de gouvernement est en place comment ça
se déroule là-bas à l'assemblée
l'assemblée du nunavut
c'est ça une des choses pas qui est
moins connu qui est peut-être méconnu
c'est que il ya des gens qui pensent que
le nunavut
c'est un territoire oui ça territoire
une autre mais que c'est aussi un
gouvernement il nous est comme un
gouvernement autonome inuit
oui mais c'est paul qu elle les inuits
à l'époque quand ils ont voulu créer un
territoire se séparer en fait du retour
du norway savoir un territoire
strictement
i know it il y avait un intérêt lot de
il y avait un élément
d'autodétermination la danse au c'est
sûr et certain
mais en voulant créer en voulant créer
un territoire est aussi un gouvernement
à l'époque qui ont décidé que ce serait
un gouvernement public c'est à dire que
c'est pas comme j'ai dit c'est pas un
territoire un gouvernement autonome
inuit
c'est à dire que techniquement à
l'assemblée législative ça pour être
100% des noms inuit son député du mmm et
l'assemblée législative du nunavut
mais en réalité les gens vont plutôt
bien et les gens élisent en majorité des
8 mai c'est pour vous expliquer que ce
soit un gouvernement public ça
représente tous les inuits de pardon
tous les nouveaux modes qui sont tous
les citoyens du nunavut
mais quand on regarde en fait la
population c'est la population est à 85%
inuit 15% non il nous est donc c'est
vraiment un mélange le 15 pour ça y'a
des gens qui viennent de partout dans le
monde
mais ce n'est pas une fête alors ci
dessus c'est une population très très
très largement inuit et le gouvernement
doit desservir la population qui était
nous est mais ça vous le disiez
actuellement tous les députés au pouvoir
à l'assemblée législative sont quand
même inuit
oui je pense que oui en ce moment la
plupart du temps c'est souvent une
grande majorité
mais c'est une autre histoire quand on
parle de la bureaucratie
voilà terme de les employer les
fonctionnaires ces lots
je pense que c'est une j'ai l'impression
que ça peut être une des plus grandes
déceptions depuis la création du nunavut
c'est à dire que oui les moutons on
sacrifiait beaucoup pour dans la
négociation du territoire mais il y
avait des promesses qui avaient été
faites à l'époque les gens oui voulait
un territoire un gouvernement public
mais il y avait des il y avait des comme
des conditions au des promesses dans
l'entente entre autres c'était dans
notre entente territoriale ça dit que la
bureaucratie
les fonctionnaires devraient refléter la
population et comme j'ai dit c'est à 85%
inuit
alors que depuis la création du nunavut
au gouvernement du nunavut et au
gouvernement du canada au nunavut la
moyenne ça a toujours cette année à peu
près à 50 % donc que ça ça fait que la
bureaucratie à 50% de la pop des
employés qui parlent pas la langue pour
la majorité qui parlent pas la langue
locale qui est une petite ou qui ne sont
pas du nunavut qui s'opposent au heat
qui en fait qu'ils connaissent pas
vraiment où entre leurs connaissances et
moi intime de la culture est en fait du
mode de vie des citoyens qu'ils doivent
desservez oui alors elle est là la
grande difficulté parce que justement
les citoyens lorsqu'ils vont chercher
des services souvent ne on ne va pas
leur parler dans leur langue
c'est ça la langue du travail devrait en
principe être le lait nous petit toutou
ou minou inactive mais c'est vraiment
beaucoup les choses pas ça en anglais
aussi les services gouvernementaux les
programmes peuvent pas être offerts
toujours en innu petit tout si les
employés ne sont pas un mais minutes ou
ne parlent pas eux mêmes les nos petits
tout est en fait moi défaut pour faire
des parallèles pour remettre à remettre
en contexte j'essaye des fois de
comparer au québec parce que j'ai de la
famille au québec j'ai vécu au québec et
je me demande est ce que ce serait
acceptable au québec de dire je m'en
vais un bureau du gouvernement du québec
et je peux pas me faire servir en
français par exemple ou que la moitié
des employés dans le bureau en fait dans
toute la bureaucratie ne parle pas
français ne viennent pas du québec par
exemple
mais ici c'est c'est pas une certaine
comparaison exact parce qu'ici non
seulement on est en territoire inuit
c'est grâce aux inuit et la bataille
qu'ils ont menées comme vous avez dit
depuis plusieurs années pour en arriver
à la création du nunavut c'est grâce aux
inuit que le terreau tour d'ulm a voté
xix ce que le gouvernement existe et il
faut il faut vraiment pas perdre de vue
qu'il faut toujours continuer
des efforts pour pour avoir un
gouvernement qui reflète vraiment la
population
oui alors parlons-en de la langue avec
quelli che et les chemins gouvernement
publics du territoire du nunavut a été
établie donc en 1999 la langue inuit
elle était au coeur de ce projet de ce
grand projet on va expliquer tout de
suite on pas ce que je dis la lande
d'ouée mais il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs langues parlées chez les inuit
du nunavut
oui on va juste que globalement les
énigmes et a réussi à l'ask canada
groenland
c'est la langue mais il ya plusieurs
dialectes et même les linguistes inuits
sont pas d'accord sûr il convient de
dialectes comment les définir
oui au juste au nunavut mal de
nouveautés crime unodc tout pour
englober toutes les dialectes dans les
territoires parce qu'il ya une attitude
qui est le dialecte qui est parlé par le
plus demandé nous mine actuelle mais
aussi d'autres dialectes
mais de nouveau écrit ce thème lors
d'halloween octobre pour que quand il
parle de la langue inuit ou 9 août que
tout les dialectes soit conclu d'accord
alors lorsqu'on parle de l'état de la
langue
vingt ans après la création du nunavut
on se rend compte qu'ils allaient très
précaire en fait quand on a créé
territoire qu'est ce qu'on espérait pour
la langue
oui mais comme madame de l'eau à dix
c'était de toutes les gouvernements
public
la vision c'est de pouvoir livrer toutes
les services et programmes on en use est
un lieu au fil des années la législation
qui était mise en place qui est mis la
longue du est comme langue officielle au
même pied que l'anglais est français il
ya d'autres législations qui a prévoyez
une éducation bilingue anglais et ne
peut tout jouer jusqu'à la fin de
l'école secondaire
oui alors on voit que toutes les lois
été mise en place il ya une grande
volonté mais malheureusement on n'est
pas les objectifs que les gens les prévu
il ya 20 ans alors parlons de la
situation de la langue actuellement mais
c'est comme notre invité a dit la
majorité des services sont toujours
livrés en anglais est une autre chose
juste avec le personnel dans le
gouvernement du nunavut
c'est vrai ce que le deal de 50% sénat
très rester là mais il faut dire que
dans les positions comme gérante les
plus parisiens sont en cours dans les
positions administratifs et les gens qui
décident les programmes est tous assez
souvent les gens du sud et ça roule
tellement c'est même pas nécessairement
les gens qui restent ou nous le foot
pendant des années non c'est ça la
grande difficulté marie vous êtes
d'accord avec ça n'est ce pas un c'est
ça c'est un point d'achoppement pour
essayer de préserver la langue avec avec
toutes ces difficultés là oui exactement
et moi comme vous avez dit je viens
d'ici relancer ma ville natale et j'ai
vu tellement de changements depuis que
depuis que khalid a été déterminé comme
étant la capitale mais depuis ma
jeunesse aussi comme par exemple quand
j'étais plus jeune on était environ à
1500 2000 de population maintenant ici
on est presque à 7000 donc une
augmentation considérable puis aussi ici
alors on attend plus souvent parler en
anglais par exemple comparativement à
certaines plus petites communautés
c'est ça c'est un impact
absolument alors au départ ont
évidemment on agissait de bonne volonté
qu'est ce qui finalement n'a pas
fonctionné et liche
mais comme si on parle avec 100
personnes des flottes au nunavut on va
voir sans réponse des fans pour les
solutions les chances ratées mais on
veut dire une femme qui reviennent
subventions pas juste de langues et
l'éducation oui c'est qu' il n'y a pas
assez d'enseignants en ligne est pour
offrir une éducation bilingue à travers
les territoires
ça c'est un défi il ya un invité va me
corriger si on domicile ont même fait un
gros projet pour essayer de former les
enseignantes mais il n'y a presque pas
les ressources adéquates pour prendre
les programmes est vraiment un deuxième
long terme pour répondre à cette pénurie
est vraiment un manque criant des
enseignantes en ligne est à cause de ça
qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure de la
législation pour l'éducation bilingue
c'était prévu de commencer que ce soit
fait en juillet 2019
le gouvernement est pas capable de faire
ça y est maintenant une loi intérimaire
pour rapporter une implémentation de cet
article que l'éducation bilingue va être
inférieure à travers les territoires
jusqu'à la fin de l'école secondaire
règlement discuter maintenant est-ce
qu'elle va modifier la législation est
ce qu'il va leur rapporter ce seuil est
encore en discussion maintenant mais on
est dressée comme vraiment qu'on parle
dès que les gens ne nous fait c'est ça
qui ressortent souvent la queue il n'y a
pas les moyens qui étaient pris à
l'entente pour régler cette question de
locuteurs pour enseigner les langues
inuits mais ils n'ont pas les diplômes
qu'il faut pour faire cet enseignement
là c'est ça et puis le comme jeudi les
programmes qui étaient mises en place
mais il faut deux choses allaient qui
côtière qui est la présidente une
nouvelle gamme bic
quand j'ai parlé avec elle pour ce sujet
elles sortent les chiffres c'est comme
vraiment celui dont un peu comme le défi
c'est que le multi tout maintenant on
perd à peu près une personne parrainée
et si ça continue en 2051 et avoir juste
4 % de la population de nouvelle qui va
parler la langue nouvelle langue
maternelle louis alors le problème c'est
que ysl problème qui traîne depuis
longtemps ou même temps qu'ils aiment
déclin dans les usages de la langue
inuit du nunavut saut il faut vraiment
les que les moyens soient pris pour
rendre ces sommes maintenant c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut laisse traîner
parce que comme madame gauthier à cadix
comme il faut que l'expédition
maintenant bien sûr oui parce que la
situation est de plus en plus grave et
ça va en s'accélérant finalement oui est
ce qu'il ya des mesures concrètes qui
sont prises par le gouvernement pour
essayer de changer la donne écoute là
ils reviennent la législation en
principe est excellente en crise aux
sociétés mises en place la volonté est
là pour les programmes maintenant j'ai
parlé avec le ministère de
de patrimoine du patrimoine et puis de
la culture et des sur le terrain et le
cdh imprimantes et les choses et les
données par comme exemple dans les
dernières de trois ans il ya 700 livres
qui étaient développés pour aider la
lecture on à minuit sur l'éducation
il dit aussi les deux travaillent très
étroitement avec la région de plus de
west d'une nouvelle équipe team origin
c'est là qu'il pas une usine actuelle et
si on dit que les petites routes et
précaires inactive il ya maintenant
juste 495 personnes qui parlent le
dialecte comme langue maternelle
alors le ministre travaille très
étroitement d'extrusion l'heure pour
mettre les programmes culturels ou
lignine actuel fait partie de ça
pourrait donner une visibilité et de le
promouvoir comme une langue vivante
selon et jeunesse et puis aussi c'est
comme un anecdotes mais aussi dit si on
voit les dernières vingt ans par exemple
maintenant de deux dernières de trois
ans on voit de plus en plus ils disent
qui sort de les groupes rock pop ou une
voûte qui sont langues
on en ligne est est peut-être le salaire
comme pas grand chose avec toutes les
défis dont on a parlé mais quand on voit
que la jeunesse
et puis klein artistique prend la langue
inuit oui c'est quand même un système
disent que c'est encore quelque chose
très important et que ça fait un lien
avec la jeunesse
alors il faut dire les choses qui sont
en place mais en corse et on est dans
une situation assez précaires quand même
alors parlons-en du dossier de la langue
comment ils évoluent donc actuellement
mais comme je dis c'était comme un gros
sujet un gros dossier weave dans les
semaines et mois qui viennent
on a parlé de la législation qui
d'arriver à une nouveauté est ce que ça
va être modifiée à porter annulé on sait
pas ce seuil et suivre mais aussi cette
semaine à new york une grosse rencontre
à les nations unies pour les affaires
autochtones et puis madame côtière de
nouvelles tingwick et l original elles
étaient présents et que la présenter un
rapport sur l'état de l'éducation et la
langue renouveau et le rapport à la
conclusion que le système d'éducation
en train de perpétrer un génocide
culturel et linguistique au nunavut
alors comment on dit c'est quand même un
dossier très chaude et puis c'est
vraiment quelque chose à suivre dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent alors
marie on ne va plus vous interrompre
maintenant parce que vous le voyez la
ligne est un peu difficile d'allier un
petit un petit écart alors on va enfin
vous donner la chance de vous exprimer
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de la
langue la de ce qui se passe
actuellement avec cette visite à l'onu
de cette dame et de la tangente que ça
prend tout cas en ce qui concerne la
langue inuit
je dirais que je suis d'accord avec
certains commentaires que vous avez fait
plutôt dans le sens qu'il faut agir
maintenant
parce que quand il s'agit de la langue
c'est ça peut prendre juste une
génération avant que ça se perd ça peut
aller tellement rapidement et aussi pour
garder
qu'est ce qui peut encourager
l'utilisation de la langue aussi les
médias la télévision et chez qui je sais
que des groupes
le cours qui veulent créer un poste un
canal pour avoir des points seulement
des nôtres qui n'ont pas encore réussi à
avoir le soutien qu'ils ont besoin pour
y arriver il ya des groupes des
organismes sans but lucratif qui qui qui
créent des émissions qui veulent avoir
un centre d or et d or de la scène comme
une salle de spectacle et tous ceux pour
préserver la langue pour préserver la
culture n'ont pas encore réussi à avoir
le soutien nécessaire pour que ça
devienne une réalité
il ya des mais il ya beaucoup d'efforts
quand même âge des nouveaux
communautaire comme par exemple aider
des entreprises privées qui créent des
émissions de télévision en inaptitude
même avec peu de ressources
alors c'est à travers les médias aussi
qu' on on encourage l'utilisation de la
langue
et puis il faut pas oublier que
l'historique tellement restant les
pensionnats on a vécu c'est ici où le
gouvernement a vraiment mettre mis
tellement d'efforts argent ressources
pour éliminer notre culture notre langue
pour enlever tous les aspects de notre
culture c'est tellement restant donc
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'il faut
agir mais
non il faut que autant des fois ci non
plus du gouvernement et soit mis pour
donner la chance de regagner la langue
revitaliser la langue et mettre toutes
les ressources pour que vraiment on a
les outils nécessaires pour pour
préserver la langue ceci on est on est
là on est rendu là il faut vraiment agir
maintenant donc je suis d'accord avec
les les les airs de dire que les efforts
doivent être ni maintenant oui alors on
parle de la fragilité de la langue et
donc de la préservation qui est
importante
parlons aussi de la fragilité des
conditions de vie des inuits elle n'est
pas évidente du tout on le voit
d'ailleurs on montre des photos depuis
tout à l'heure on voit que la pauvreté
est très importante au nunavut
c'est ça comme quand on regarde la
moyenne des les revenus moyens
chez les inuit est environ 20 mille en
moyenne ou nunavut chez les inuit chez
l'ennemi nous est la moyenne est environ
90 milles
donc vous voyez que ya une disparité
sociale une disparité économique entre
nos lignes 8 et inuit qui est incroyable
et même à 20 millions à 20000 de revenus
par année même dans le sud nous on
appelle le sud le sud du canada mène
dans le sud les gens on aurait de la
difficulté mais si le goût de la vie
vous le savez peut-être c'est deux trois
fois quatre fois plus cher pour tous
donc sa cause la pauvreté extrême
puis juste ramener encore le contexte
historique mais vraiment pas lointain
l'autre jusqu'à récemment les gens
vivent encore sur le territoire même la
monnaie courante si c'est intéressant
pour nous les hutus nunavut est très
très très récent pour vous dire ma mère
est née sur le territoire et est sur un
bâti tu as écrit comme un lac le nom
d'un tel acte i sais même pas par nature
qui est la communauté qui est écrit la
plus près c'est
je vous dis ceci c'est mon vécu c'est
mon vécu dans ma famille c'est les
changements radicaux ont été tellement
rapide par exemple ma grand mère qui est
décédée sur son bétail à la justin non
parce que nous avant jusqu'à 6 récemment
on avait juste un prénom c'était comme
ça mais le gouvernement est arrivé avait
du mal à prononcer no no no no on avait
des comme des médaillons avec des
numéros
ma mère aussi numéro là et maintenant de
la vie quand on aujourd'hui les
changements étaient tellement rapide
cela il faut pas l'oublier et ça n'a pas
été sans conséquence on a perdu des vies
en chemin et c'est vraiment c'est pour
n'importe quelle société d'avoir des
changements aussi rapide
c'est sûr qu'il va avoir des
répercussions mais il faut il faut
mettre les ressources il faut mettre
il faut mettre centre avoir de
l'assistance aussi oui il faut
absolument mettre les ressources là
dessus comme par exemple d'un sud
il ya des cycles d'investissement en
infrastructures ou même le système
éducatif formel vous avez des siècles
d'expérience avec seule l'économie basée
sur le salaire la monnaie courante
soucis et nous quand on pense que ça
fait 20 ans que le nunavut existe quand
on regarde le contexte c'est pour
beaucoup le vin étant en fin de compte
mais alors comment les gens se
débrouillent avec un salaire de 20 mille
dollars par année comment on fait on
trouve pour se loger
non il ya une énorme crise du logement
non seulement qui est passé de logements
pour les besoins il ya sa cause et
surpeuplement de logements et des
familles entières qui vivent dans une
salle de lavage
par exemple il ya des gens qui vivent
dans des sharks sur le bord de la baie
ici c'est comme juste une bois une
cabane en bois il n'y a pas d'eau
courante pas d'électricité même à moins
les gens doivent se chauffer avec du
comme pro pas mais ça vient des dangers
de feu il ya des
donc c'est pas comme s'ils vivent avec
vive bien à moi à 20000 par année n'ont
absolument pas il ya de la pauvreté
extrême et c'est absolument inacceptable
oui et puis vous l'avez dit aussi juste
le panier d'épicerie parce que oui une
fois que le bateau est parti
s'il nous manque des réserves il faut
aller les acheter à d'épicerie on va les
payer
combien de fois plus que que nous qui
vivons dans sud ouest zac te ment mais
des statistiques récentes qui ont sorti
comme de quoi il ya sept enfants sur 10
qui vont à l'école en ayant faim il
éducation l comment ça se passe pour les
jeunes ont parlé de la langue donc
actuellement ils apprennent les outils
tout jusqu'à la troisième année du
primaire on espère évidemment que ça va
se rendre jusqu'à la 12e mais sinon dans
les écoles donc les professeurs ce ne
sont pas la plupart des professeurs et
luigi joubert inouk
j'imagine que ce sont des professeurs
qui sont venus du sud qui repartiront
dans le sud au niveau de l'éducation le
décrochage scolaire est très important
oui j'ai politique ni rien mais je pense
que oui oui il ya pas que les
professeurs les directeurs d'école
pourtant s'il y avait des programmes
par le passé quand qui ont eu beaucoup
de succès pour créer des professeurs il
nous est même maintenant le programme
je pense que des programmes des
changements au niveau du programme au
collège ici et quand quand une situation
qui capot l'air de marche il faut
vraiment regarder c'est pourquoi puis je
peux certaine que ce c'est ça ça a
vraiment été fait
oui mais aussi si c'est au niveau même
les les juges à la cour les avocats
c'est presque très peu des nues et la
grc la police
médecins infirmiers
infirmiers infirmières donc on voit que
ce sont sa c'est ce que c'est mais ça
fait que les gens peuvent pas être
desservis dans des services essentiels
comme la santé ou s'il a les services
juridiques l'école tout seuls dans leur
langue
parlons-en de la santé un hôpital
seulement un hôpital qui est à ical
woods qui est ce que cet hôpital à
couvre tout le nunavut les 25
communautés du nunavut
après ces puits mais pour certains soins
spécialisés les gens doivent aller dans
les centres dans les villes comme par
exemple ottawa winnipeg ou edmonton
selon la région
si nous le votons couvre trois fuseaux
horaires c'est une victoire énorme c'est
pour les services spécialisés mais sinon
dans les communautés il ya comme un
petit centre centre de santé et donc
l'accès l'accès aux médecins l'accès aux
infirmières l'accès aux soins de santé
l'accès aux psychologues travailleurs
sociaux au niveau de la santé mentale
est très limité pour certaines personnes
alors que on est au canada c'est ce
qu'il faut se rappeler on est des
canadiens on est on est au canada donc
on devrait avoir un traitement égal
accès aux soins égal aux soins de santé
de base au moins
mais c'est mais c'est pas le cas aussi
par exemple les personnes âgées on n'a
pas de centre de soins à long terme pour
les personnes en danger donc doivent
descendre déménager dans des villes
comme par exemple à ottawa oui où ils
vont passer leur jouera loi de leurs
communautés pas desservis dans leur
langue loin de leur nourriture pour nous
les inuits notre nourriture
traditionnelle est tellement importante
ça nous enrichit sa c'est c'est
tellement important et c'est même pour
les personnes âgées
alors ces conditions de vie en bonne
santé est adéquat mme asma ben oui ces
conditions de vie difficiles ont des
répercussions le voit sur la vie des
gens entre autres en ce qui concerne la
santé il ya une recrudescence d'une
maladie qui était presque oublié la
tuberculose causés par la proville à la
pauvreté la promiscuité également c'est
ça c'est en compte ces maladies à saison
et qui a été éradiquée par à plusieurs
endroits dans le monde et au canada et
met ses traits c'est encore trop commun
ici au nunavut
entre autres le surpeuplement le les
problèmes de logement et tout ça c'est
alors avant de parler quand même
d'aspects positifs parce que j'espère
qu'il y en avait isabelle vous avez une
question pour un mari oui oui en fait
j'ai vu en mars dernier qui allait avoir
un nouveau programme de justice
thérapeutique ou communautaire mis en
place ou nunavut pouvez-vous nous en
parler un peu bonne question je pourrais
pas vous donner toutes les détails à ce
moment par rapport à ça
c'est en fait de ce que j'ai lu c'est
que c'est un programme qui allait être
basé plus sur la prévention que sur les
châtiments les punitions donc la
réinsertion mais par la culture donc ça
vient rejoindre d'autres grandes qu'on
voit un peu partout au canada concernant
les autochtones qui sait peut-être une
solution
intéressant ce serait une solution oui
alors ouais habituellement il ya des c
c'est plus un lien aussi avec la culture
inuit le de vraiment s'asseoir puis de
regarder comme on peut réinsérer la
personne c'est aussi réintégré parce que
nous on vit dans notre communauté on va
pas vraiment aller nous portons c'est
notre chez nous on est là pour rester
donc faut vraiment trouver une façon de
recréer l'harmonie et ç'a toujours été
la façon inuit de fer en vivent dans des
petits dans des petites communautés de
vraiment agir d'une façon qui préserve
l'harmonie et les relations involontaire
la justice réparatrice finalement marie
à quelles sont les avancées pendant ces
vingt années là le temps de temps file
pour nous mais pendant ces vingt années
là quels ont été les avancées
importantes pour pour les inuits
vous avez fait un peu allusion tout à
l'heure en parlant des z'arts les
artistes on a énormément d'ambassadeur
inuit qui sont connus à travers le monde
des producteurs de films des chanteurs
des producteurs de documentaires des
acteurs vraiment le monde des arts est
en ébullition il ya énormément de talent
un style
c'est cela la créativité abonde autant
au niveau des arts visuels
les sculpteurs les artistes visuels
aussi les arts de la scène et mais se
sait je trouve que le soutien dont ils
reçoivent souvent des groupes
communautaires des organismes sans but
lucratif qui vont soutenir les artistes
et les avancées je trouve c'est vraiment
les communautés eux-mêmes qui s'organise
qui crée vraiment des belles choses des
beaux programmes
il ya même une compagnie privée qui
quittent commune est école de langue
privée qui pour ce qui est de la langue
inuit aussi les transmissions de la
culture on a des idées des autres des
petites compagnies qui vont produire des
émissions en inuktitut de même avec peu
de ressources
on a des centres où on peut apprendre
des aspects de la tradition comme côte
des comics qui sont nos bottes en peau
de phoque des hameaux qui sont nos
manteaux pour porter les bébés ya la
transmission de la culture qui est qui
est vraiment riche mais c'est vraiment
des groupes communautaires qu'ils
prennent sur eux mêmes et qui vont créer
des projets des très beaux projets aussi
qu'ils ont beaucoup de succès les gens
sont intéressés et continue et ça
préserve la culture c'est vraiment ça
crée de l'emploi de l'emploi important
pas juste un emploi quelconque mais
vraiment un impôt qu'est de la valeur
pour pour la personne et pour la
communauté
quand vous vous tourner vers l'avenir
quel espoir avez vous qu'est ce que vous
espérez quand on va reparler du nunavut
mettons dans 20 ans qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu'elle changement vous voulez
vous qui êtes était implantée d'ici là
j'aimerais avoir les conditions de vie
des inuits amélioré d'une façon pourquoi
puissent avoir une vie digne et décente
comme tous les canadiens
ce serait le minimum de voir aussi la
langue se préserver les gens les huttes
vraiment et en déposant de pouvoir être
dans des poissons peuvent prendre des
décisions que vraiment toutes les
programmes servis soit vraiment centré
sur les inuits la culture il nous est
locale dans le fond c'est ça la
population du nunavut et puis aussi
qu'on a vu le la bataille qui a été
menée pour créer le nunavut et les inuit
qui ont fait ça c'était comme une tâche
quasiment impensable à l'époque mais on
a réussi
donc on va continuer de lutter on va
continuer de
persévérer comme on a toujours fait et
j'ai l'espoir aussi en regardant
d'autres places dans le monde comme par
exemple au groenland
ils se sont retrouvés dans une situation
un peu similaire à nous les gens étaient
envoyés au danemark pour étudier
revenait par le plus le danois mais
maintenant quand vos groenland tout
c'est pas ça clashe les soutiers leur
langue et ont vraiment une fierté
on peut y arriver c'est pas impossible
c'est sûr qu'on va y arriver ça va
prendre les formes et 30 ans qui nous
étonner pour même pour sauver dans le
climat dans lequel on est l'article ça
prend une soif de vivre extrême ça prend
une force intérieure
c'est ça qui on est en temps qui nous
est ce c'est jamais parti alors on voit
basé sur qui nous sommes la force qu'on
en a tant qui nous et on va continuer de
persévérer
d'ailleurs on le voit malgré toutes les
difficultés que les inuit on a traversé
sur ce territoire
les gens ne partent pas ou envie d'y
vivre et c'est votre cas où si vous
restez haïr alouettes vous restez sur
place oui absolument j'ai passé
plusieurs années dans le sud pour pour
les études mais ces moments chez moi je
vivrai pas nulle part ailleurs citi
c'est notre territoire selon on peut
parler notre langue vive notre culture
transmettre nos traditions notre vie
communautaire les communautés sont ici
très serré aussi le climat de vitres et
saint louis fait foi mais l'arrêt pur on
est proche de la nature c'est vraiment à
cette fois quelque chose qu'on peut
retrouver dans les villes et il ya
vraiment beaucoup de beauté ces puits
il fait bon vivre ici c'est sûr que
malheureusement souvent on dira les
mythes sont tellement résilient où on
est résilient parce que c'est notre
nature d'être comme ça mais je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on ne devrait pas être
aussi résilier dans ce sens que les
défis que sont mis devant nous dû entre
autres au colonialisme la colonisation
qui est très récente
saleh des impacts qui sont vraiment pas
nécessaire on devrait pas être aussi
résilier mais on l'est et on percevoir
malgré tout voilà c'est votre mot de la
fin merci beaucoup marie bellot merci
d'avoir accepté cette invitation à être
avec nous aujourd'hui à bientôt
rien ne m'étonne merci merci beaucoup et
lee chez isabelle encore une fois
d'avoir participé c'est une discussion
vraiment intéressant parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un territoire qui est
tellement pas oublier les trop peu
connue en fait oui oui il est méconnu
mais ce que j'entends ce que ce que je
vois c'est la même réalité que ce que
d'autres autochtones ont vécu plus haut
ce dont il se répète malgré une certaine
reconnaissance territoriale et une
autonomie
voilà elisha dernier mot oui j'ai juste
joué avec les invités viens de dire sur
la colonisation
de secours très intéressant maintenant
comme le président de nous lever tout
gober qu'elle dit pam en matière de
langue que c'était le gouvernement
fédéral qui avec les pensionnats
autochtones que pendant les années où
l'argent pour investir dans de partir
les pensionnats autochtones des
embauches et des enseignantes et puis
elle dit il faut vraiment qu au canada
aucune discussion maintenant est ce que
les gouvernements devraient pas prendre
le même argent pour essayer de renverser
le déclin de la langue inuit louis dans
l'arctique alors beaucoup de discussions
beaucoup de choses bonnes questions
encore à se poser merci beaucoup à vous
tous d'avoir encore une fois participer
à cette émission et je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine au revoir
[Musique]